[Music]
Cooper today you go to boarding
school no sit cooper cooper
sit who are
you oh cool guy back there I don't know
where we got to TA you jumped some hoops
to get there my dad my dad said I went
from out from my mom China that's crazy
was but I did not do that yeah you
squeezed your way out on your mom's
China no but she wasn't
crying he's going to have a
blast hey
Google can you show me a video of he but
in live action without pretty stuff and
doubles what
look how clear this water is look at
that you can see the Rocks underneath
but not that but not that c it's still
green it's still green you're
[Music]
right she wants all the smoke what are
you going to do now
what you going to do now
huh
okay you missed him that's I said to be
in Europe you said yeah we're in a
beautiful
palace reminiscent to how Tao was made
no the the Greeks lived oh okay yay the
family's
here everyone is excited Ed to go in the
backyard because we've been seeing a lot
of movement back here so we think
there's going to be a lot of updates so
we got Mama taer right
there look at that nice you all right
dude no oh no what are we going to do
got take to the hospital monkey yeah
today what are we doing right now going
to the Dan and how do you feel about
that I don't know are the monsters
living in there nothing I can see
yet you put water in my mouth no that
was just
air and water in your mouth is
saliva CU there a water out from my
mouth use a spoon you freaking
Neanderthal I wish I had
Chopsticks oh smells so good look what
we see a baby
donkey look monkey you see that baby
donkey over
there but look at
that that at
that all right what in the world is this
seef
big6 oh yeah's birthday party today
happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you we could
probably find a place where we could
swim and stuff yeah let to swim sure
your KN that one was pretty
scary go you hold the right side I hold
this side okay how cute does this
look hold it nice and tight we kind of
messed up with this one this Mammoth one
it's not as cool as the other ones but
it's kind of cool it has a year has a
year and has a big elephant like the
picture he
took does your long hair feel good on
your back T is letting his hair grow by
the way you don't want to cut your hair
anytime soon no look at
[Music]
me that's cute I'm dying right
now put your hands together for jeza in
Earth Shaker a for clubing open for the
first
time
ready
you didn't take a breath in the middle
yes I did you did no you didn't don't be
a liar no I don't think you
did that's a breath right there that was
a toe touch
up leave it there so keep going you
leave it like that I'm like it it looks
good it looks like a like that you sure
yeah it looks good but he just brush all
quite a hey
off he brush the with the he
[Music]
up
wa
cool anyway on that note I'm going to
take a shower change rest up call a day
thank you so much and again always
always always always always so damn
grateful for all the love that you guys
give me and my family like we'd be
without you guys so thank you again love
youall good night